in one time I had to go to the bathroom
so bad number two
now oopsie Daisy I was in public but I
don't care dude you know what I do
you know what I do when I gotta go to
the bathroom in public number two do you
know what I do I go bathroom in public
number two
because that's how it is dude
that's how it is if toilets are around
I'm using them if I gotta go I don't
people with oh germs and [__] like that
that's how you get sick
and I don't use I don't you dude I only
use the [__] the thing you know what
I mean the the cover I only use that
when it's necessary
like if there's some blood on the toilet
seat or something
I wipe it off I get a lot of toilet
paper I wipe it off
I wipe it off so it doesn't touch my
hand as well
and then I put the thing on only if
there's like blood or [__] or piss
but if there's nothing on there and I
look at it and you know what I do I give
it a once over
that's all I do I give it a once over
and if it's got nothing on there I don't
use it because it's just touching my
thighs dude if pitch touches your thighs
I don't give a [__] bro I'm living
oh my God Chris you sat on the you sat
on the on the toilet bowl what about
getting piss and [__] all over your
balls
is it on my balls
or is it on my thighs
[Applause]
so
I do it and I don't give a [__] dude
because that's the kind of life you got
to live on gangster and if you're out
there and if you're going to the
bathroom number two and you're not using
those [__] safety things
let me know
and I won't read it but tweet it at me
and I won't read it
um so I don't do this at one time oh
also if if the woman's room is open I'm
a chick
that the man's room if the men's room is
uh is is [__]
um used occupied
and the woman's is not
I'm a check
apparently I've got a [__] cause I'm
unloading
I'm unloading in the women's room
ah
dude
Hey sir what are you doing it looks like
you got a penis and you're going in the
women's room
well apparently right now I'm
a female
[Applause]
oh my God are you strangling an
alligator am I or am I
taking a [__] bro
[Applause]
so I went into the thing the ladies room
and it wasn't a single stall and guess
what dude
you [__] up the way you made this
building
because this is still
coming out
all right
so I go in the women's room and I tiptoe
because now I'm a woman baby
and I go in the stall
you know how women always tiptoe so I
will I go in the stall
and I close the door
and then uh
and then uh and then I close the door
and then and then I'm going right I'm
going and it's all good but I'm going it
wasn't an Out Burger but even still we'd
have fun with the keyboard so
um so I'm in there and I'm going and a
lady comes in and it instantly I don't
know why maybe it's because I'm a [__]
my knees get real close to to each other
because I'm scared and I don't want
anybody to see my balls and I'm trying
to [__] be real real tiny so nobody
can see me even though I'm still six too
and I'm a tall drink of water right and
my shoulders of course are [__] they
go on for like do you want to know what
the weather's like on Thursday because
my shoulders go into next week
you know what I mean you want to know
what the [__] weather's like on next
Thursday well let's take a ride on my
shoulders
[Music]
shoulders go on for a week so let me
know where you are and I'll tell you the
forecast
all right
so
are those your shoulders yes and it's
raining on Friday
anyway dude I went in there and my knees
were touching together
because I scared because the lady
[__] came in
and she was tiptoeing because she's a
lady and ladies always tiptoe ladies
have never not tiptoed and
I'm trying to be quiet I'm trying not to
let print come out or anything like that
you know what I mean
try not to strangle any Alligators and
she's like
she says
did a guy come in here did anyone see it
no she said did anyone see a guy come in
here
and there's the sliver
of the V the way they make these stalls
dude make them so there's no way to peek
in
you know there's always like a gap
That's like [__] two inches wide and
you could just literally make eye
contact with people while you're [__]
dropping off
you know what I mean
so
so she looks at me
after she said oh she said does anyone
see a guy come in here and I go like
this
I go like this
I'm like should I make my voice like a
woman like should I literally go no but
I'm like no I'm not gonna pass for that
right
if it were nowadays I would have just
been like
no and I know you've got you hear my
voice but I identify as a woman I would
have [__] done that now but this was
a while ago so I just I was like should
I go no and I was like nah for [__]
sake you know one time when I was a kid
one time I was a kid I didn't want to
talk to him uh it was I was in high
school I was in eighth grade and this
kid was actually even wanted to hang out
and I didn't want to hang out and he had
my number because I would have cell
phones back then and they called me and
he was like hi uh uh I picked up the
phone and I was like hello and he was
like Chris and I was like [__] he's
gonna ask to hang out and I said oh no
this is Chris's mom Ellie
and he was like oh
is Chris there and I said and I
literally I literally said
I I this is the truth I swear to God I
literally said oh no he's at the Opera
and he said okay well tell him to call
me back it's David or whoever I don't
remember who it was
And I said Okay click and I remember
thinking well he'll believe that because
why the [__] would I pretend I was my
mom and say Chris was at the Opera
because what the [__] there's not operas
that go on it [__] well maybe they do
I don't know but not not near La Canada
at 5 pm
so anyway I uh I didn't do that voice I
just I said
she said did anyone see a guy come in
here and I said no and I as I say no I
look at out the the crack of the doors
and I'm making eye contact with her with
one eye
and I'm looking at her and I say no and
she just said did anyone see a guy come
in here and I say no and I'm a guy
oh
and then
oh no I didn't say no I said what I said
what which is even better that's so much
of a [__] I was she said you ever see a
guy come in here and I said what and I'm
looking at her
uh God
and she says uh and I S and then she
says again and I swear to God this was
the only time this ever happened in my
entire life she said I said did anyone
see an iPhone in here I heard the wrong
thing because I was scared I'm a [__]
that was the first that was the only
time that ever happened to me it's like
that happens in movies and you're like
okay go [__] yourself dude go [__]
yourself you know but it really happened
and I said oh no no iPhone and she just
walked out tiptoeing like a lady
and I finished up strangling my
alligator and then I walked out a man
but that was what was up that day dude
did you know that so
it was good man one time my friend said
he was in a foreign country with his
brother and he was drinking with his
brother and he and his brother
uh couldn't find his brother for a
little bit and he was outside and there
was a huge pile of throw up on the
ground and he was leading up against the
wall and my buddy said
hey did you just throw up and he said I
don't know
caught red-handed
I don't know
head
I don't know dude not straight up lie no
I don't know is the best
to say I don't know
when you know
and you're trying to get out of not
being a [__] you know in trouble or
whatever you think is the best I don't
know
I don't know
that's my favorite kind of [__] and
that's final so you can [__] argue
with me all day long but that's my
favorite kind of [__] and that's fine
because we know what we like we know
what daddy likes we know what [__]
daddy likes daddy likes when guys are
[__] a [__] and they try to not be a
[__] that's the best thing if a guy's
wearing sunglasses at night and bumps
into a [__] thing
that's my favorite thing and that's the
end of story dude
okay